hundreds of top-secret documents a leak
from within South Africa spy agency and
given to Al Jazeera's investigative unit
it tells an incredible tale of how
Africa's most powerful spy agency
interacts with other spy agencies and
when they talk to each other
we often get a far more truthful account
of events than the officially declared
narrative Israel's Mossad appears in
hundreds of the documents these are just
four things we learned about Israel from
the cables and boy are some of them
crazy the papers show Mossad bombards
the SS a South Africa State security
with cable after cable of foil terror
plots potential terror plots
hypothetical terror plots etc one cable
from the Mossad says the terror attack
on Israelis in Bulgaria in 2012 was
originally intended to target Jewish
interests in South Africa another top
secret cable warns the SSA of a possible
imminent shipment of yellowcake uranium
to Iran from or through South Africa via
and Armenian broker
they were the blueprints to a
sophisticated anti-tank air-to-ground
missile called the mo coppa missile and
they were stolen the official story -
South African men tried and failed to
sell them to Israel in Russia one went
to jail the other became a state witness
and got a fine but the cables say
something completely different the
Israelis did manage to get the plants
and then they gave them back only on the
condition that their citizen involved in
the theft wasn't prosecuted and guess
what the South Africans agreed to the
deal South African intelligence believes
that Israel's involvement in Africa and
in particular Foreign Minister Avigdor
Lieberman's visit to five African states
in 2009 was an exercise in cynicism
meaning they believe there's zero
sincerity there
the cables also confirmed that Israel
did as has been widely suspected
collaborate with apartheid South Africa
to develop South Africa's now dismantled
nuclear weapons the Goldstone report was
a UN fact-finding mission after the Gaza
war in 2008 and 2009 led by prominent
South African jurist Richard Goldstone
it found blame on both Israel and
Palestinian militants but it crucially
said Israel had committed potential war
crimes during the war the top-secret
cables revealed Israel spy chief called
his South African counterpart urging him
to try to do something to vote down the
Goldstone report at the UN he also
claimed that Israel had a crucial ally
against the report the Palestinian
President
one cable suspects Iran of using
civilian fronts in South Africa like
carpet shops to gather information